Ngày hai người thằng sau thủ tưởng thái lan và phép tổng tăng xin ở trà tới thằng khu tăng giác ngọt lục bảo,
ở tình ubong ra chả thán y, giáp bình giới với các buồn chia trong bối cảnh tăng tháng ngoại giao dựa
hãy nước liên quan đến trân chấp bình giới đang giá tăng theo báo dân nè sình và phép tổng tăng dự kiến gì chuyển bằng trước thăng đến khu hành trình đôm
vê các bạn pháp tăng cường ở những bình giới và bảo vệ an toàn trong vệ dân khu vực. Chúng đỏ trong cuộc đại đàn ngày 15 thằng sau,
bà phép tổng tăng đã quy chết nhiệm cho tư lệnh quan khu hai về việc để căng thẳng bình giới giao thang.
Nông thời có cách xin hô thân mặt về huon dên, lối dung cuộc gọi sau đỏ được việc căng phù trưa công bố,
giống tối lạn sống chỉ trích mạnh mẽ từ phải đối lập trong nước, cáo buộc bà làm tổn hại hình anh của nụ thái lan.
Đối diện với áp lực giữa thủ đường phép tổng tăng đã công khai xin đối vào sáng em ở chiến hàng sau,
khẳng định bà không biết cuộc cho chuyện đã bị giơm. Tăm giáng ngọt lúc bảo là cuộc bực tiếp giáp giữa thái lan,
là vào công bù chia còn được công bù chia gọi là mùm bay, phía thấy là là trong bốc.
Cung bên quan đình trình chấp tạc của phục này, ngày 15 thằng sau, chính phủ công bù chia đã gửi công hảm chính thức lên toàn công li của thế,
là dưới thêm giải pháp cho các tránh chấp lên quan đình các khu đình tạm mọt thông, tạm mọt tốc, tạm các bây và cuộc mông bay.